I mean she's so great in this and I love
seeing her on and screaming Morgan as
well they're just there's such a great
combination did you we just did you just
know that they would be brilliant
together oh absolutely I mean I wrote it
for Florence I didn't know who the and I
and I I wrote it thinking I'm gonna
aspire to get some senior just legendary
performer I never imagined it would be
Morgan so when we got Morgan and I I
there's a scene in the diner where
there's sitting opposite each other in a
booth and I I just the idea of This
brilliant ingenue that everyone's so
excited about opposite this legendary uh
actor in his 80s to me that's the movie
I I was like I don't know what it's
about but I want I want to see that
movie I want to see these two people go
head to head
um and so I was thrilled when when he
said yes